Hello and welcome to the next video in our exercise, in this we are going to be programming
the gameplay behavior.
So for this I would like you to open up GB underscore sitting now, this is our gameplay
behavior.
When you open it up you will get a screen just a little bit like this.
Now this is a data-only blueprint at the moment.
What we are going to want to do is add code.
So if you come up here you will see that there is an option to open the full blueprint editor.
If you click on that you should get something that looks like what we are more used to working.
What I would like to do is first come up to the functions that are overriding.
And what we are looking for is the on-triggered character.
There is a number of on-finished and there is a number of untriggered.
But different events are going to give us different pins that we are going to be able to access.
And this isn't a task, it is part of the stature, so we are not using the variables
and the context to get data in and out.
So I am going to select on-triggered character.
Now it is going to bring up this build.
Now I am going to be referencing these values quite a few times.
So to make it neater I am going to save out a couple of these two variables.
So the first one I want is the power timer.
Right hand click and you can see we have an option to promote to variant.
If that in it creates the variable and we are good to go.
Now the second one is the smart object owner.
So what I would like to do is right hand click and again promote that to a variable
and plug that in after you have it.
Now after I have done this the first thing I want to do is turn off the collisions on the share.
Now the collisions are going to be different smart objects.
So I am not going to hard code it here.
What I am going to do is drag off of the smart owner object
and I am going to go turn off collisions.
You can see our interface we have an option to turn off the collisions.
So that is going to send an interface message to just turn off the collisions.
It is a nice quick way and we will put the code on the smart object itself in a minute.
The next thing I would like to do is I want to make sure we have the look target set up correctly.
And we saved that variable to the AI.
So unfortunately we are going to need to do a cast at this point to make sure that we have it.
So I am going to drag in the avatar and I am going to cast to BP underscore NPC share from the end.
And once I have that I am going to get off of the pit.
And once I have that I am going to drag off and I am going to find the smart object transform.
I am going to get the smart object transform swap.
This is the variable that we made in that piece of pre-written code.
And then I am going to get component by class.
And the component that we are looking for in here is the motion warper.
Motion warping component.
And I am going to add or update warp target transform.
I am going to plug that in and I am going to connect that to the cast like this.
Now there is one last thing we need to do and that is set the warp target name.
In this instance the name is share.
So just set that to share.
That is quite straightforward.
Unfortunately this is the only non modular part at this point.
But what we are doing is we are just updating the warp component so that we can see it play.
Now we are all ready to play the montage.
What I am going to do is I am going to again grab the avatar.
And I am going to go play amy montage.
And we have the animation montage here.
We are going to promote this to a variable.
And in the defaults I am going to search for sitting down.
So that is our animation montage.
This is the first time that we are playing animation montage.
Now you may have noticed that we are using this animation montage node not the normal one which
has the calculate pins for when it ends.
That is because we are unable to use those kind of nodes within the gameplay behaviour.
So we have to be a little bit cleverer in order to make this whole thing run correctly.
So the first thing I am going to do is you see this return value.
This is going to return the length of the animation in seconds.
I am going to promote this to a variable.
I am going to name this animation black.
And I am going to press slide.
So we are just running the animation and record the map.
Next up, I will have to wait until this animation has finished running.
And have a bit of idle time in the middle.
So rather than having the outlet pin what I am going to do is drag off and go set timer by event.
And we have an input for a tiny.
So what I am going to do is grab my animation length and I am going to add to it.
I am going to add three seconds and plug that output into the timer.
So applying the animation, wait for however long the animation is.
Plus three seconds and then it is going to kick off our new event.
So I am going to drag off here and go add custom event.
I will name this custom event.
Stand up.
So for this custom event, I will do two things.
I am going to create a sequence.
So I am going to do two things relatively immediately.
Now the first thing I am going to do is I am going to bring in our avatar.
And I am going to get the mesh.
And from this I am going to play a montage.
So and I will switch.
I am going to plug in the montage again here.
Now I already know the type so I do not need to use the other one.
So it does not really matter because I am not using the outlet pin.
I am using the sequence here before.
But what I would like to do, what I need is this starting position and this play route.
So what I am going to do is I am going to get the animation length.
And I am going to plug that into the starting position.
So that means we are going to start at the end.
However, I do not want the play route the length to be one,
I want it to be minus one.
And that is so we are playing it backwards.
So what this will go away and do is it will run the animation backwards,
starting at the end.
I am not worried about any of the other outlet pins I will miss.
That is all I am using this for.
And once this animation has run,
we are going to have to come out of this.
So again, I am doing what I did before and that is set timer by event.
And we know this is going to run for the same amount of time
so I just need to plug in the animation length.
Now I am going to drag off, add custom event.
And this event I am going to call stop,
montage.
Now there are a couple of ways that you can stop the montage,
but our goal is to go back to the previous animation.
Now one of the things we have not mentioned before barboring this up
is if we were to go away and actually look at the montage itself,
double click on the montage,
and then we are going to go back to the animation.
So we are going to go back to the animation.
And the montage.
You can see that we have a couple of pods and sobs in here.
First one is we have our motion warping section at the top here.
So I just add in, add state motion warping.
So that is required.
How to get the motion warping to work on the animation itself.
We need to make sure that we have root motion turned on.
So let's have a quick look at that.
So if I was to fire that up, this is the animation.
In the details, we need to make sure we have the enable root motion here.
Fire that back to our montage.
The other element that we need is
we need to disable the enable auto blend out.
And it's a very simple reason we're doing this.
It's because when we play the animation, we're sitting down,
we want the character to stay at the end of the animation.
So we're turning off the enable auto blend out.
However, this does also mean that we're going to have trouble
coming out of the animation.
Because without a blend, it's not going to seamlessly convert
back to the animation blueprint.
And that's why we're doing the little bit that we're doing next.
So we went back to the sitting down, we're stopping them on touch.
Now there is a node that will allow us to just directly
stop the montage.
The problem with that is it can jump back to the animation blueprint
and it will pop out because there's no blend.
So what I'm going to do instead is I have created another animation.
Just call transition.
And it goes to select here.
There is very little to it.
But what it is is it is the character in the idle mode,
which means that we can now blend out this animation.
I'm actually giving us a relatively perfect blend.
So I've created this and all that it is is a very, very short section
of the idle animation.
We've the blend out automatic KNA.
So that we don't have to have the plot at the end.
Okay, so how I'm going to do this is again, I'm going to drag our avatar.
Then I'm going to drag off and get this color to mesh.
Pick any of these to color down some of this way to do that.
And I'm going to play in one.
So I'm going to hem into the next element out
and move it to theíamosos Location Se understandable,
because it has to see this entire section,
but then I'm going to match all the appeared
video pregunta with everything else that I made here.
And what I'm doing now is a flow-ish exchange
and control and see.
And thanks for sticking with us with that one, then next up we're going to finish off
some odds and sorts and get this up to Nuremberg.